based on the tooltips I've been reading
it sounds like controller might not be
optimal for this but I guess we'll see
might not be optimal I'm committed to
controller at this point all right okay
so left and right is this all the blue
go forward I'm only gonna God what what
what what I saw was a mure cursor at
where you want to ring what what I'm
feeling pretty good about my keyboard
math decision how do i forward it 36
come on man Lego what but that is no
sense that makes no sense it makes
absolutely no sense how would you
navigate it's okay it's okay you'll
figure it out yes let that is yeah
listen you don't need to get oh no
listen it's it's 2020 it's not 2015 our
base humor needs to be much higher than
when this game first came out
dicks dicks dicks dicks dicks dicks
dicks dicks yeah okay listen I'm glad
you haven't changed in the past five
years but some of us have become right
more it'll never change how the hell did
you do that this is oddly beautiful like
you have to admit there's something
that's there's something about the
majesty of the human form yes I think we
can all agree that these human forms are
indeed majestic cry my sound up on this
game got it you gotta let them hear the
grunts man yeah I like that this is one
hand only for me this is chill I'm into
this see I can't go forward I can only
orbit around I have to grasp at the
ground in front of you yeah but see the
thing is I with a controller I cannot go
forward can you change the perspective
of your camera with your right thumb
stick ah that's what it do okay I see
which is an extremely limiting way to
play but play I shall about the keyboard
the mouse I feel like it's really
ringing true
you'd think though you would think that
that
joystick would be better oh hell yeah
sir oh man what a move oh my god I am a
god music is awfully dramatic it hits I
like how in the other one it was just
like this one is like you are witnessing
the majesty of human achievement I wish
I hadn't gone full ball I mean you got
to go full dong if you're gonna mount
this mountain you have to Palmer jahres
inca you got this Palmer oh I didn't
even realize these guys had names yeah
they're all characters you have like a
team of food I'm using controller I'm
trying to figure out how to get it right
and get it tight okay so that's a whip I
can't really grab there we go I feel
like if I get this it'll become wool oh
excuse me
I need to borrow this please oh Jesus
there's something like majestically
beautiful no no oh God
okay oh God
see the thing is okay here's the problem
oh my god the problem is grabbing is not
like holding down so it's so you have
like a reserve pool that's all of your
extra time god oh god I did it again I
tried to grab with my other hand at the
top I'm like okay I need no holiness
obviously but no I'm need to hold it
there we go
well use up all my take flop and once
you get peak it just turns a three
second countdown once you're above the
plane and you just have today above the
plane I'm still waiting for the I M
bread multiplayer update I would love to
become a loaf with you guys work you
love that right that game angered me to
no end
it's a skill based game which is what I
really love about it well okay that's
something I can recognize that it is
relatively skill based because at least
its controls are consistent if you
understand them Wow Jesus Christ at the
top of my goodness you know me that's
what they called me perfect Jesus not
like that other guy imperfect Jesus what
a [ __ ] Lord no I'm saying guys you know
I'm saying please keep talking about
this yeah get them this is a good topic
for discussion
the nips kill me I don't know why I
don't mind the dogs my mind the nips oh
I've got it
I was trying to get in your face if I'm
honest I didn't quite get what I wanted
out of that mmm okay so I gotta let go
to reach is the thing okay there we well
don't grab it crabs automatically yeah
it's grass when it touches your just a
grabby boy you know I feel like I feel
like a disadvantage with the gamepad
which doesn't make sense you know like
I'm the only one on keyboard and mouse
to be clear oh warned you I gave you
lots of warning switch your control
scheme you actually you kind of just
don't like oh right when you're at the
very climax yeah
[Laughter]
move or fully at 90 degrees that's what
I called the power thrust baby you
thrust to the heavens show imperfect
Jesus who's boss
I don't like the way the camera spins
around and you get different angles of
everything part about this I thought I
was signing up for listen if you can't
appreciate the glory of the male form
then I don't even know if I can call you
my friend
what are you are those male apologists I
don't know what position I'm in position
is what that is they call that the
tender embrace it does blow my mind that
this this physique is the goal of like a
lot of bodybuilders oh there we go cuz
cuz to be to be perfectly asked if we're
just gonna like it step outside the meme
for just a moment this is like it's
incredible that the human body could
become this but also it's horrifying
oh yeah no it's disturbing yeah Oh every
time I see bodybuilders especially in
person there's a moment or two of like
wow what did how'd you do that and then
it's followed quickly by like don't
shake my hand like Oh covered in oil oh
my God look at this fellow's eyeball
who's Ebel I ball poor mans eyeball he
he trained to earn that eyeballs look at
how look at how squishy and bigoted yes
uh-huh I know look I don't want to push
you mark but you're low on reserved time
so you really got a hustle look I don't
need to hustle I've got the muscle
[Laughter]
inspire the muscle this thing oh yes by
spoon span you just see spin yourself
around you spawned yourself weights
always going for that goat ass I do like
to go to s yeah what is it what is the
tensile strength
goats ass can it support his weight well
he said it's not us it's mostly on his
little titties there no face
what's the tensile strengths of these
guys dongs like it can it support
someone crapping I'm oh I know the
ultimate achievement would be all right
grasping in three dimensions the dong of
one of these fellows as your as your dog
ya see what we're doing is we're only
going for height we're not going for
elegance we're not going out we're not
we're not making art here I like the
delay where I hear you scream like three
seconds before anything goes wrong yeah
totally fine I think the most disturbing
thing about this other than the visuals
is like the really uplifting like
Olympics ceremony music happening with
it I don't know what music you're
getting I'm getting a depressed minor
her like Symphony gone on air yes you're
welcome
yep bring some elegance to this affair I
apologize for saying we weren't making
art here because holy [ __ ] beauty oh my
god see that hold right there oh oh oh
oh I'm wrapped I'm wrapped I'm wrapped
I'm wrapped you hate to see it I'm
cramped my muscles no help you know you
got how high is this
[Laughter]
possibility crap I laid it perfectly and
you walked right into it like a fool
you're right I am the fool I needed to
turn up the slap sounds I want is some
delicate Pat's
as you grasp now there's supple buttock
Oh Oh God there we go yeah that's a
tango right there yeah don't get rapped
over here yes oh good luck Bob I got
this keyboard and mouse aficionado
I'm so good you seem to have the way to
go with the mouse
no no it's it's like it there's a
learning curve to the gamepad but I
believe that it allows for more
intricate nimble ventures Mark's not
gonna let facts or evidence get in the
way of beliefs gamepad can provide Wow
not what you want to see no what do you
know I want to see this I don't know if
the assets worth this amount of time I
think you got to really get up there
whoa what's this sticker in the top
right you can you can put emotes on the
scree great very useful the perfect form
Jesus Wow Wow no door Oh Dora the
Explorer and how will I ever handle this
rod Zhang I think everything isn't a
dick joke okay his name's Rodney he
likes to go by rod dude I was
complimenting his awesome name for your
entertainment he's here to do one job
that is to have a great name of this
heap of majesty and create true arts oh
listen listen if your name's rod Zang
I'm gonna both clap and laugh because
it's amazing
Oh
but grabbing on to that majestic pose I
won't have fun grabbing on to that God
you guys look like you're having so much
fun mark do you like this sure do it's
it's a blast and a half I sort of
thought Wade would lose by doubt well
that's a good start
I'll be waiting wrap what are you
talking about oh it wraps nerd
oh my reserve time well weights not
gonna be winning now wow you know we've
all been getting past those legs the
entire game Wade so at least I got
wrapped up at the top you know Barca
lost inches from victory okay yeah yeah
at least you could live up to that
legacy ya know all my reserve time there
goes there going oh my gosh
no don't do it no go away oh all that
face oh he's liking that yeah he's
really enjoying being on top of that
thing I wouldn't wouldn't you wouldn't
you wouldn't you man I guess so so does
the keyboard allow you to push forward
and backwards in addition to going up
and down yeah well so it is my hands at
whatever my mouse is over so I don't
even have to really care about
orientation if I only mouse over one of
the guys it'll just move it in the
correct direction to grab oh that's so
much easier
literally have been saying the whole
time is it just like left and right
mouse button yeah I've not even used in
my left hand it's all keyboard baby I'm
gonna try it always best to change up
your control mechanism read the crux of
the action you really want to switch
everything up that you can yeah this is
so much better everytime we're like mark
this is way easier it's just another
inch further away he moves from ever
trying it ever well I was literally just
I was just saying like hey it's good
ridiculously easy
well alright I'm gonna still do gamepad
but listen you're not doing nothing
about
highly recommend against that I don't
think mastering gamepad comes anywhere
close to precision well you know in the
next hour when I'm able to play again I
guess you know I'll uh you know I'll
give it a try I still pronounce the
mouse he will finish this before he gets
to reserve listen I got I got to go get
my thesis statement done you just kill a
few hours these the statement did you go
back yeah yeah I thought about you know
I had time to consider you know between
now and the last time I played I was
really pontificating my thesis for my
bachelor's degree that's weird
yeah well you know I'm going for a
master's at the same time oh wow yeah
it's a combo program
oh it's floppy well you barely at the
dip in the resort okay okay are you just
trying to get content mark I'm sorry
worry about where you're bothered by
this kind of hurry
no no nothing I understand you know I
love brain I love everything love
playing games with my friends you know
being able to participate is the
greatest thrill in life if you used
Mouse like we do yeah you might get your
wish mark I'm taking this one for the
team buddy
I'm bringing you back all right I
appreciate it I don't like where the
dicks pointing towards the camera yeah
that's good that's good stuff yeah
mm-hmm give us a dance yeah I do I do I
really do oh can you pole dance on the
pillars find out hope the grace I mean
answer is yes absolutely
acrobatic garage dancing I've ever seen
oh oh you've seen nothing yet
ready for that dong action there we go
that is
the finisher look at that finisher yeah
one all right all right I'm gonna show
you what gamepads all about I show you
yeah you do it man retire that gate pad
mark you'll be out now what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna look at the controllers and
see if we're missing something you know
what I mean you know yeah okay as it
turns out it doesn't seem to be
suggesting any changes to the gamepad
it's almost like it doesn't want to
support the gamepad however I will not
let it stop me I will play who did both
I can tell you for a fact the gamepad is
inferior and you will lose that's a lot
of talk for someone who lost the last
round oh you did get him the tower was
twice as tall after you left
we're playing a game mode called spiral
by the way all right I was hoping for
that one this looks the same what's
spiral all about I don't know I guess
you nerds will have to find out oh you
get 60 seconds no reserve interesting
interesting interesting jarred Umberger
good good start good start
excellent start excellent I'd say all
right those keyboards really holding you
back I bet look at and come on I got an
geez man oh wow yeah this is great yeah
great keyboard add the spiral there we
go making a spiral locks oh my that's
different
all right okay well I thought was gonna
hey good luck with that gamepad mark I
think that really gives me an advantage
in this game mode I think it does I
think it does I think it does I think
you're ready to admit your faults Oh
delightful
Oh the bodies disappear oh no
interesting interesting
looks like the game pad is gonna really
bring the win for me you keyboard
warriors do you hear the man's
confidence yeah yeah
oh ho look at all the bodies this wage
yeah the dogs go away oh why couldn't
they just leave a bikini like on the box
the pelvis stays from each human in
attach to the edge of the box yeah oh
all the students try and look at
[Music]
mid-back flow that is dope but not dope
enough you keyboard loser watch the true
controller show you the business and
this is good I'm wrapped you like that
you'll like that
I'll look at my kiss hi I'm a pretty
Bowl become the course you see I don't I
don't see why they couldn't do this do a
version of this with women grabbing you
a boob you know that that would give you
a lot more grasping surfaces if I'm
honest if I'm if I really think it's
right - though what a what a delicate I
was gonna say what a delicate ass in my
face but I guess not anymore yeah well
when some loose oh no you know what
someone with a keyboard couldn't pull
off a glorious flip like that you might
be on somebody I am onto something I'm
on to the top of this mountain and
that's clearly not a game yeah oh man oh
you are the Hulk kind of a sick Hulk
nice throw feeling under the weather
Hulk maybe some black bad clam chowder
Hulk oh no the keyboard let him down
inferior control devices will often
cause there is a there's a price to
losing this round as I will never ever
let that go it for like the rest of them
I would never let it go it's okay it's
basically impossible for me to lose this
round because weights not very good and
you're using a gamepad the clearly
inferior decision I might not be very
good but you don't three honest about it
I I'm always honest I'm the nice one and
I never tell lies I think we've
established that pretty handily well
come on grab me we've established
happens if I avoid you entirely get
you've got it you got the answer hey
grab any second now it's the gamepad
it's clearly an issue it's not the
gamepad it's me all of my flaws are but
I have a gamepad so I'm there for the
gamepad is the only thing keeping you in
it exactly exactly
all right try not to flip myself into
space how do you start off by throwing
yourself to release both hands at the
same time once you get one hand moving
forward if you release your back hand
you like keep the momentum so that you
can you can literally Huck yourself hmm
more like Huck your keyboard out the
window because it's so frustrating
I would like to grasp of this man's who
eat like that not my keyboard oh yeah
I'm hurtling through the air at such
speed with such grace and His grace that
is speed I will not deny that didn't
work at all get him Wade if there's a
timer can you throw yourself upwards
like I figure you have to be grabbing on
to the top part you can't be I don't
actually know if that's true I wonder if
you're just in the air above the plane
long enough if you just freeze wherever
you are when the counter stops that
would make it more interesting to try to
get on up yet hello a play yeah wait I
wouldn't recommend you try it with just
you've got some time to burn just see if
you alright on the dog you like right
let go as you fling up and he's not
gonna do it he's a coward
yes I'm sure as much as you seem to
enjoy watching Bob and I play for 30
minutes I feel like I want to play a
little longer you know I did it was it
was at the time of my life I I have to
admit you learned a lot about yourself
right exactly I learned that I actually
don't want to go back to college I'm
happy where I am
si grab on this have you learned that
you want to use a mouse yet no no no
absolutely not I don't think he needs it
I think he's killing it I am killing it
thank you
see that little traversal we couldn't
have pulled that off no way no how we
would have just gone up the freeway
that's not the Let Go button
I might try it if I get if I get into a
spot where the jumping seems feasible
oh please reach the other way there we
go stupid keyboard I knew it I knew it
your mic was live haha you silly I mean
the blue does technically stay so
started started doing it it really did
can I have never for thirteen or for the
full three seconds oh I don't think I
got it guys to jump it you would have to
be like in the air for you have to get
some momentum yeah all right die well I
won't i won't laud that over you Bob
because you returned on a thing I was
bold you were bald right I tried and I
went you went for it you went for it and
you really really you showed us the
business I was seconds away from success
I was there yeah I mean three seconds is
the maximum amount of time you can be
away but I was just under three seconds
away from success yeah yeah yeah
continue kicking your ass is so sound I
don't know about alright I think you
hold it up and then leap like you have
to get the timer going and then go for
it
you could up maybe made your way back up
there wait I could have like you really
gave up pretty soon there listen Bob
tried a thing I didn't want to keep Bob
out he team worked hard
looks like the superior controller has
won out yeah I think you outsmarted the
other players you know what I really
tricked you guys all right we're playing
low gravity frickin yeah now it's just a
game of who can launch themselves most
efficiently and I think we all know who
that's gonna be
May thank you
say Oh dramatic oh my god it's really
low gravity yep okay that's not that's
not what I meant
hang on uh-huh what I said yup what I
meant was yep
goddamnit so the timer didn't even start
that time for being a high it did on my
screen in it I don't know maybe you saw
it I didn't see it yeah yeah I don't see
where it counts down below
good luck nerds oh wait not counting
down definitely would have done it if it
was do I right right okay so that's not
make sense make sense no worky that was
special that must be a special low
gravity rule I swear but you can
definitely hook yourself up the mountain
yes you can go for desperation chunks
AUSA's jump desperation chunks yeah yeah
chunks oh man I gotta get used to like
the let go hey you know what they say
the superior control schemes take much
longer to learn and are just
counterintuitive in almost every way oh
my god there you go I was a delicate tap
I made it eventually I kind of wish
you'd grab me by the dawn but I respect
the fact you not so what is the what
does let go on keyboard like is it's
just mouse no keyboard it's just mouse
buttons left click right click aim and
that sounds really easy gives you an
arrow telling you where you're able my
god Bob suck it that's super cool
wait a minute wait a minute probably the
left of the let go confusion I got this
oh you didn't grab no he's getting
he's applying to another level Bob how
can we compete I actually have about a
thousand hours and this game do I have
him by the dog got kind of the dong just
missed the doll the legs though I mean
the legs are so thick how are you
supposed to reach in there yeah I don't
know I don't know how you get to the
dong oh look at this guy get used to the
letting go idea cuz if I throw it oh
there's a mouse it's you there look at
that that was worth it yeah okay where's
this dick there's this dick gimme oh my
god don't go that way
come on God controller sucks good god
there really is no fine control reserves
Natick happy reserves oh it's it's
documented yeah yeah got the big blue
dick under there definitely look at that
you're not you aren't even good at this
game if you touch the ground before you
get on the tower anymore but I read of
course all right you guys who just
called me about my name that's fine
wait you're not very good at this game
are those nips look at how glorious not
to the nips to stand out on the blue on
the blue man I really can see nothing
but the nips at this point Oh tippy top
uh well I kind of touched the ground I
guess it's not on it thanks me I like it
when I don't like it alright mr.
Manhattan I'm gonna grab you by the nip
dr. Manhattan mister doctor now I guess
the kneecap is where I wanted did anyway
that's my thigh come on now oh by the
tippy toes you were higher than me I
gotta give it to you
this a superior controller coming I
can't grab a goddamn the problem with
control is I have to move the camera
like also at the same time so it's a lot
more there was another way to play wait
wait wait I have an idea we're going out
baby nice I wish you would kept the leg
shape I really like that what's wrong
with the colors of my dudes not not good
colors for dudes to be yeah he looks
like a guy that's been through some
problems we're gonna we're gonna go this
way
mm-hmm really get the I'll get the tip
and then we're gonna go fully fully
horizontal wow what a guy wasn't lead no
joke big big hearts big hearts on that
one oh my god we're unlocking new emotes
guys what the Wade you're cheating wait
don't cheat wait wait come on come on
man going out we've we've all
collectively agreed by just doing what
the previous person didn't need to stop
there but I guess I'm holding you by the
head about that that's good let's tease
ah that's good that was pathetic
I really touched correct you grabbed
grass did I did not enough electrolytes
to keep these muscles going I mean I
can't imagine how much hydration you
must need to stay that ripped all the
time dude I haven't hydrated in years I
wanna I want to marvel at our works
theories oh no need I almost touched
grass like a dweeb I think you did I
think I think I saw a little bit of a I
grazed it look okay I did I didn't grab
it like some people here I do no need to
talk about Wade like
camera if you could help me out here
it's like inside the tower Wow beauty
that is nice
my dog is pointing in the direction yeah
oh wait no oh that was neat I don't I
thought it was going to be totally let
down now five saw to two stars oh so sad
can you leave a good rating on Yelp for
me no I don't want to rush you Wade but
you've only got eight seconds yeah we're
gonna start dipping into reserve time no
I've lost it completely
what happened am i amazing like leap
into forever oh the one time you really
had it down what doesn't what's going on
what I can't grab anything there we go
seems like a you problem listen Urim is
like a problem problem like I'm like a
block more than anything else
I don't got climbers block kids that you
won't this is epic comeback
just you wait this is this is just this
is so sad I know it's a no idea what
happened to me come on do it
oh my god you weren't using you save
that look man a desperation oh god just
move for oh my god oh my god oh
can't leave cuz I didn't let go god oh
my god
what happened there just like nothing
the frantic screaming didn't save you
can't exploit I can't explain what
happened to that one nothing worked the
way it originally had worked I think the
way we built the tower is really pissing
off the camera system I was Florrie
falling for a moment just my little
[ __ ] up there haha the good tits my
little [ __ ] alright wait mark that's
only gonna go on for like 40 or 50 more
minutes I can't throw myself to save my
life after this I'll try one more I'm
gonna try the keyboard and I'm gonna see
I objectively to know if it's all yes
objectively we all know that mark is the
best at being objective piece ish yet
are you
objective you're the one who wouldn't
let go of the controller literally and
figuratively because I wanted to
challenge you dick hole that's true
I complained because if suddenly I
it was completely inept at being able to
control and there's a difference Bob the
nice one so to speak the only one
showing divisive NISP in our group I'm
beginning to suspect to think that
you're not the nice one at all I am the
nice one
mmm say something nice about me then I
really like how short you are that
didn't feel nice but it sounded nice oh
for God's sakes listen get him thrown
off my crew mark wait say something nice
about me I need a comparison you've got
hair that's not a nice thing though I
don't and it's not nice to not so maybe
just take the compliment mine feel nicer
no I think it did I think we can all
great
I think what I think the problem here is
that none of us know how to complement
each other in a serious way that's
probably true I don't do anything
seriously yeah where's the character
development going on where's the growth
uh where's the where's the diversity
where's the disney-like love in this
where's the princess which one of us is
the prince and which one is the villain
I'm definitely the variable marks
definitely the prince can see but wait a
minute the way you cannot say that that
was mean you don't want to be the Prince
no no I get it but but but no but that
okay now yeah I see the game you're
playing I see it Bob I see it you're
saying why you would be the wheel no no
you're saying you would be the villain
so that people would be like oh no no
Bob you wouldn't be the villain
therefore people typically extolling how
I am the villain I know I didn't see
well my suspicions I had my suspicions
but now you're trying to you're trying
to you're trying on new people to your
siding and being like oh no you're not
develop wait a minute wouldn't that be a
very villainous thing to do no but now
that's reverse psychology and say
something nice about wait I really like
wades dogs they're cute yeah I did a
good job being about wait I get it you
say ah I see I see it now I see it all
started unraveling for where's the yard
go mark what's the board following it
down I'm following it okay
all right let's see all right say
something nice about Wade's dog I think
it's really cute how gingers name is
cute
I count it wait no but that dog didn't
have a choice in its name so it's not
something nice about that wait a minute
why wait don't you see it yeah he said
gingers name was cute no no there's
layers he's a maniacal
genius but now we don't know if he's
Knights are really the villain because
he's painting himself to be the nice guy
but saying it could be the villain but
no and would agree with that because of
the things that he's saying on their
surface or objectively entertaining and
nice however look a little deeper you'll
see soon I need some more examples right
now I'm not seeing it yet sorry Bob
say something mean about me you're not
as funny as you think you are all that I
was actually mean I'm sorry but that
felt nice I don't even know how to be
how to be ruthless oh man yeah you're
apologizing about you be like oh I don't
want to say it but then you followed it
up immediately with something else that
was also me it was like saying like it's
it's not saying no I'm not racist but
it's that thing like I'm not the mean
one artists hahaha wait what do people
don't agree with me that I'm the villain
not yet
evidence is inconclusive just give me
one man just give me one no no no that's
what you want me to say and then then
I'm the bad guy no I'm the if I'm the
villain I'm the bad guy that's not how
this works
[Laughter]
Bob's truths were just too much for me
to handle
but were they the truth were they I mean
we had several discussions about how I'm
actually the villain of the group no but
no no one who sews all the discord no
instigated by you and let by you no wait
what I mean not led by you like a
witch-hunt but like you star you where
you drove that conversation in how you
were observing that I'm not actually the
nice one wait
so it's my fault so are you I mean
that's okay if you want to be like I can
all agree on one thing I'm not too evil
one
[Laughter]
[Music]